oh you're
you are yeah
I'm Batman flashes and Batman's and a
Supergirl oh my The Flash is finally
here after what ironically seems like
forever but now that it is the buzz has
rightfully built into full-on serious
anticipation for what promises to be a
Multiverse jumping a nostalgia-inducing
spectacle so you might be wondering
who's in it what's it all about and how
exactly does it fit into the dceu and or
the new DCU we're here to answer all
those questions and we're gonna do it in
a quick amount of time stop right there
I'm in here's everything you need to
know before you go see the Flash
[Music]
you're strapped to your parachutes and
where's yours
it's gonna be a fast I mean fun one so
let's do it
plans to make a Flash Film have actually
been kicked around since the 1980s with
various writers and directors attached
along the way that is until the 2010s
when the movie was redeveloped once
again as part of the dceu and with Ezra
Miller cast as the lead that led to
brief appearances by Miller in 2016 in
both Batman v Superman dawn of Justice
and Suicide Squad the following year the
role was expanded much more for Justice
League where Miller teamed up with
Heroes like Henry Cavill Superman Ben
Affleck's Batman and gal gadot's Wonder
Woman to take on the bad guy Steppenwolf
who is that again
Miller has also reprized the role on TV
in the arrowverse crossover event crisis
on infinite Earths on the CW and as a
cameo in the max series Peacemaker as
far as what the flash is about we know
that elements of the film were
influenced by the flashpoint story arc
from the comic books in 2011 which
centers around an altered DC Universe
and features plenty of crossovers it's
not quark
my name is Cara I I'm more Barry in this
film Barry who's still in the Justice
League uses his powers to travel back in
time to change some events of the past
including saving his mom from being
murdered but those actions mess up the
future and he gets trapped in a world
without superheroes but with General Zod
now back to wreak havoc now is his
chance to finally say Neil before Zod
all I'm saying Neil before I saw it so
Barry reaches out to Batman and no not
the one played by Ben Affleck that we'll
also see in this movie I'm talking about
Michael freaking Keaton whose revived
character comes complete with his 90s
era Batmobile and his bat wing o m g
listen they said that in the 90s all
right you want to get nuts
let's get nuts Barry will also team up
with a younger version of himself also
played by Miller and a Kryptonian
Castaway named Cara zorel AKA Supergirl
and again I say OMG
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this you know I wasn't
just gonna gloss over a couple of
Batmans that we thought we'd never see
again right so let's discuss Michael
Keaton is reprising his role from 1989's
Batman and 1992's Batman Returns which
for the sake of this film took place in
an alternate universe meanwhile the
events of Batman Forever and Batman and
Robin from the mid 90s which Keaton
wasn't in will be ignored for this movie
but let's be honest we can ignore Kilmer
and Clooney as Batman for a couple of
hours but we'll never ever forget bad
nipples I freeze I'm Batman and while
we're rattling off past actors that have
played Batman it's worth noting that Ben
Affleck's Bruce Wayne slash Batman will
also play a major role in The Flash
especially considering he is the version
of Bruce from Barry's original timeline
and he's also the leader of the Justice
League app like said it took this final
appearance as the character to finally
figure out how to play him right so keep
that in mind while you watch Ben do his
thing she with you
I thought yours with you now that we
have the various Batman bat man's anyone
that's not awfully PC what about that
person let's take a look at what other
characters will be seeing when the flash
eases on into the theaters starting with
the aforementioned Cara zorrell or
Supergirl she's got similar powers and
abilities and even wardrobe as Superman
the characters played by Sasha Kaye best
known from The Young and the Restless
and she is the first ever Latina actress
to wear the S we can also expect to see
Barry's father Henry Allen although this
time he'll look a bit different that's
because Billy crudup couldn't return to
the role thanks to conflicts with the
morning show so Ron Livingston stepped
in and while we love us and Billy I bet
you one smashed up copy machine that Ron
will do a hell of a job too yeah if you
could just go ahead and make sure you do
that from now on that would be great
Jeremy Irons is also reprising his dceu
role as Alfred pennyworth for this one
along with Tamora Morrison who plays
Aquaman's father in the Aquaman movies
and if you're wondering yes gal gadot's
Wonder Woman is also reportedly
returning I've killed things from other
worlds before
but after all of this you might be
wondering how this movie which was in
development and production for quite a
while fits into the plans of the freshly
announced DCU well DC Studios co-ceo and
co-chairman James Gunn said that the
flash will reset the dceu continuity
making way for what he called a soft
reboot with the DCU before its first big
Superman movie in 2025 meaning they will
pluck only certain cast members and
elements from the dceu as they see fit
while replacing others despite a handful
of people that we know will be a part of
the DCU like Viola Davis as Amanda
Waller and John Cena as Peacemaker many
of the other actors remain in limbo and
that includes Ezra Miller as The Flash
oh no so enjoy them in this one gross oh
okay so that's everything you need to
know before you go see the Flash in
theaters June 16th thanks for watching
and be sure to rate and review this film
at rottentomatoes.com
[Music]